hi there steve kaufman here again
today i'm going to talk about memory and
language learning
remember if you like these videos please
subscribe and if you like this
particular video you can always give it
a thumbs up if you want
so memory memory
you know the ability to remember things
or more than the ability to remember
things deliberately trying to remember
things in other words
forcing yourself to remember
memorization memory
is always sort of indicated as a major
factor in language learning success
and i certainly remember trying
remember
when i was trying to remember
cases in german and it didn't really
matter how often i read the declension
tables i couldn't remember the endings
at least i couldn't remember them for
very long
um so
over time i came to realize that
language learning is not about memory
now
many people
are committed to spaced repetition
systems whereby some algorithm which
presents words to you in a certain order
um
based on some scientific uh study on how
frequently and at what interval you need
to see them in order to have a better
chance of remembering them so a lot of
people do this there are systems like
memorize and
anki and others
uh there are people who invest in
mnemonics in other words they identify
words with
i don't know parts of a house or other
things that will help them remember
and i have never
really
done this
i did for a while trying to nail down
cases i had tried it again with russian
case endings or
you know conjugations of
verbs and romance languages
and
it always seemed as if i was learning
something while i was studying the table
and then later on it all evaporated
and so i have come to the conclusion
that at least in so far as i am
concerned
it doesn't work for me and i think
memory is overrated as a
an important skill
in language learning
and so if i think about the reasons why
um
first of all
there are so many words if we talk about
vocabulary it's my experience that in
order to
operate comfortably in a language
uh like now i want to understand these
podcasts from al jazeera or
uh
you know eventually hopefully uh you
know read books in
i don't know arabic or greek or whatever
i need so many words and even
getting into conversations with people
the native speaker uses
has a much larger vocabulary than i will
ever have
and so i need a lot of words so many
words that if i spend my time
deliberately trying to remember the
words i won't have time for
engaging with the language in a more
meaningful way
so even if i read something and this is
before we had online dictionaries and
link and i would read a reader in
japanese and it had a word list in
behind each chapter i would just review
the word list and go and read the text
occasionally referring back to the word
list and somehow worked my way through
the text and what was really happening
is that i was being exposed to the text
to the words i didn't know to the words
i knew
i was reading and all of that exposure
was what was enabling me to become more
and more accustomed to the language more
familiar with the language but i didn't
try to deliberately memorize that word
list
because i had found that to be a futile
task um
my memories of language
are more you know where was i when i was
listening to ipromescis posey in italian
while jogging
or
or you know cross-country skiing through
the woods listening to
you know uh
a russian novel i'd see deity or
whatever it might be
i remember
it's pleasant when we go back to
languages he learned before i still have
the font this is my t-shirt that i got
it was given to me by a friend
uh the master master and margarita
but so that i have these pleasant
memories of my previous involvement with
languages that i have learned
uh you know
and it's pleasant to do that it's like
rediscovering old friends i go back even
within the languages that i'm now
learning
uh arabic and persian and turkish i go
back to stories that i did a while ago
and i'm
rediscovering them and and
discovering you know words that have
appeared subsequently elsewhere and then
they show up there again and i kind of
firm up my sense of those words and it's
all a pleasant
uh experience of rediscovery so so that
i have learned that the key thing in
language learning is your exposure to
the language in meaningful contexts
listening and reading and eventually
speaking which is also should be
meaningful not talking about
the weather in vancouver but engaging in
meaningful conversations
uh
so that all of this engagement with the
language is how the brain gradually gets
used to the new language
and trying to rely on sort of deliberate
memorization
is not a very
you know effective
approach
and of course there's all kinds of
research
that shows i mean there's two approaches
to memorization one is
perhaps the crudest form is to try and
sit there and absorb a table conjugation
table declension table or or list of
words and there's all kinds of research
that shows that this kind of black block
learning
simply doesn't work a more sophisticated
approach
is to say that here's a bunch of things
that i have to learn
and um
using a spaced repetition system
depending on how well i think i know
them then i put these back uh you know a
couple of hours couple of weeks a couple
of months so that they reappear again
and i'm forced to try to remember them
before i've completely forgotten them
which in theory probably works
but in order to practice that you have
to spend a lot of time at it simply
because there are so many words
and
and i would rather spend my time
engaging with interesting material
rather than sitting there and
deliberately reviewing uh these words
relying on this
theory that somehow
um
you know the words will reappear just in
the right frequency i have found that
some words you remember some words you
don't
could be a whatever association or
something that makes certain words stick
and other words not stick and certain
words that you remember for a while and
then you forget and then you rediscover
them again
and as long as you are doing enough
reading and listening these words the
ones you once learned and forgot and
relearned they'll keep coming back at
you as you become familiar with the
language and if you are familiar with
the language eventually you'll start to
be able to better use the language yes
there are people who understand well and
don't speak well
don't speak as well as they would like
there is no quick solution there you
just have to keep doing it keep
listening and reading keep speaking and
fight your way through
the difficulties that you have
in finding the words you need in getting
that you know construction right just
keep doing it keep doing it occasionally
refer to the grammar uh
just to kind of refresh your memory but
just keep using the language and and
that's what what it is so that this sort
of deliberately how can i best memorize
and how can i memorize the greatest
number or in japan they have these books
of words you need to know for toeica and
i have found that in order to be
effective in the language in order to do
well on a toeic exam or any other exam
you just need such a broad-based
level of familiarity with the language
vocabulary that no deliberate strategy
of just learning these words
i is going to do it so there you have it
my take on memory and language learning
and one more thing if you uh would like
to receive my 10 email course on my tips
to language learning please click on the
link here in the video bye for now